PLACE, THEIR FOURTH TITLE IN
EIGHT YEARS.
>> DESIGNED BY JASON OF BEVERLEY
HILLS, IT IS TIME FOR THE
PLAYERS TO GET THEIR RINGS.
HERE ARE YOUR 2022 NBA CHAMPION
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
JUAN TOSCANO ANDERSON.
QUINNDARY WITHERSPOON.
ANDRE IGUODOLA.
JONATHAN KUMINGA.
MOSES MOODY.
JORDAN POOLE.
JAMES WEISMAN.
AND NOW THE STARTING FIVE.
DRAYMOND GREEN.
ANDREW WIGGINS.
KEVON LOONEY.
KLAY THOMPSON.
STEPHEN CURRY.
>> IF YOU LOOK UP THERE, THAT IS
A VERY LONELY FLAG.
WE WANT ANOTHER ONE.
>> WE BUILT THIS FROM THE GROUND
UP.
>> THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS
SELECT --
>> HARD WORK.
>> DOWN THE LANE!
>> COMMITMENT.
ATTENTION TO DETAIL.
CRAFTSMANSHIP.
THE RELENTLESS PURSUIT OF
GREATNESS FROM THE FOUNDATION TO
THE RAFTERS.
WE BUILT THIS.
>> THE DUBS DYNASTY IS STILL
VERY MUCH ALIVE.
>> FROM THE GROUND UP.
LOOK AT WHAT WE MADE.
>> IT IS TIME TO RAISE THE
WARRIORS' SEVENTH CHAMPIONSHIP
BANNER.
HERE IS THE ALL-TIME THREE-POINT
RECORD HOLDER, THE ALL-STAR MVP,
THE WESTERN CONFERENCE PLAYOFFS
MVP, THE NBA FINALS MVP STEPHEN
CURRY!
>> THIS IS A VERY SPECIAL NIGHT
CELEBRATING OUR FOURTH
CHAMPIONSHIP IN EIGHT YEARS FROM
GAME SIX OF THE 2019 FINALS IN
OAKLAND TO GAME SIX OF THE 2022
FINALS HERE AT CHASE CENTER.
THIS IS A LONG, LONG JOURNEY,
AND IT IS SUCH AN AMAZING HONOR
TO BE ABLE TO CELEBRATE OUR
FOURTH BANNER, AND THE SEVENTH
IN FRANCHISE HISTORY WITH Y'ALL
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO USE OUR
PLATFORM AND SHOUT OUT A VERY
SPECIAL MEMBER OF OUR BASKETBALL
COMMUNITY, BRITTNEY GRINER WHO
IS 32 YEARS OLD AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO LET HER NAME BE
KNOWN, AND WE WANT TO PRAY THAT
IT HAS BEEN 323 DAYS SHE HAS
BEEN WRONGFULLY INCARCERATED AND
EVERYBODY IS DOING THEIR PART TO
GET HER HOME, AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO HERE IS ABOUT OUR
TEAM.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF MEMBERS
OF THE TEAM ON THE COURT, BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS
OFF OF THE COURT, AND OUR
DIRECTOR OF PLAYER
ADMINISTRATION AND PLAYER
PROGRAMS, AND WE WANT TO BRING
YOU OUT HERE, BECAUSE YOU ARE A
SPECIAL PART OF OUR PROGRAM, AND
YOU HAVE BEEN HERE FOR 18 YEARS,
AND YOU MAY NOT KNOW HER, BUT WE
DO, AND Y'ALL GIVE IT UP FOR LA
NAY YA
McGUIGAN AND COME GET
YOUR RING.
STAY OUT HERE.
AND NOW, LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
Y'ALL READY?
WE HAVE THREE BEAUTIFUL BANNERS
UP THERE, AND WE HAVE TO ADD ONE
MORE TO COLLECTION, AND SO WE
ARE GOING TO COUNT DOWN FROM
FIVE, AND IT IS COMING DOWN HERE
FROM CENTER COURT, AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOU PUT YOUR EYES HERE --
FIVE, FOUR, THREE, TWO, ONE,
COME ON, LET'S GO.
♪ WE HAVE A REALLY BIG TEAM ♪
♪ THEY NEED REALLY BIG RINGS ♪
♪ AND THEY NEED NICE THINGS ♪
♪ AND THEY ARE COMING WITH NO
STRINGS ♪
♪ AND WE NEED SOME REALLY BIG
RINGS ♪
♪ AND I HAVE A REALLY BIG TEAM ♪
♪ AND THEY NEED SOME REALLY BIG
RINGS ♪
♪ AND THEY NEED NICE THINGS ♪
♪ AND THEY NEED TO BE COMING
WITH NO STRINGS ♪
♪ AND WE NEED SOME REALLY NICE
THINGS ♪
♪ AND THEY NEED BIG RINGS ♪
♪ AND WE GOT A BIG TEAM ♪
♪ AND WE WANT TO DO OURS ♪
♪ AND YOU AND MINE ♪
♪ ARE WE TALKING TEAMS ♪
♪ ARE YOU SWITCHING SIDES ♪
♪ YOU WANT TO COME WITH ME ♪
♪ LOOK AT THE SMILE ON ME ♪
♪ LOOK AT THE THING ♪
♪ I DON'T CHASE GIRLS ♪
♪ BUT LOOK AT ME ♪
♪ AND THIS CAN'T BE DIFFERENT ♪
♪ YOU ONLY GET ONE SHOT ♪
♪ AND MAN ♪
♪ WE WON IT ALL ♪
♪ DON'T GET TOO INVOLVED ♪
♪ WE ARE GOING TO LOVE IT ALL ♪♪
>>> THAT IS